[Music]
thousands of travel plans up in the air
this Thursday night WestJet and swoop
passengers are left in limbo I can't get
a flight now both Airlines cancel
flights as talks between the company and
the pilots Union reach a stalemate
a new look inside Alberta's Wildfire
Zone
the devastation and the smoke further
smothering a province already on high
alert
Alberta's Premier violates conflict of
interest rules the ethics commissioner's
findings about Danielle Smith just ahead
of a high-stakes televised leaders
debate
and its desperate dangerous and
sometimes deadly some of them are losing
their families a woman convicted of
human smuggling reveals why she did it
global national with Donna Friesen good
evening and thanks for joining us as a
strike deadline looms WestJet and its
subsidiary swoop have already started
prepping for what happens if the
negotiations fail flight cancellations
have begun just ahead of the May long
weekend close to 100 flights have
already been canceled planes are being
parked check-in kiosks closed the
company says negotiations with the
pilots Union have reached a stalemate
WestJet and swoop have more than 4 000
flights scheduled over the next seven
days as Canada's second largest carrier
WestJet normally handles nearly a third
of domestic flights unless something
changes about 1900 WestJet and swoop
Pilots will walk off the job Friday at 5
a.m Eastern the company could choose to
lock them out before that either way
thousands of passengers are left in the
Lurch and gaviola has our top story
WestJet said its parking planes and
canceling flights today to avoid
stranding Crews and passengers but this
family from Pei is stuck in Toronto on
route to visit family in Calgary we get
pulled out of the line and we are told
that we don't get to
go anywhere until tomorrow so
we're just kind of in limbo travel plans
ruined or postponed lives upended
already in the final hours before the
deadline they're looking at each other
uh into the whites of each other's eyes
and uh seeing who's going to Blink first
so this is really the most intense
period in any labor negotiation former
Air Canada CEO Duncan D has seen his
share of bargaining tables so you've got
the WestJet management which which wants
to compare its Pilots to the Canadian
standard
and the union that wants to compare its
members to the North American Standard
afresh on the heels of successful
negotiations with American carriers at a
time when Pilots are in high demand many
say Pilots have a lot to leverage if the
company does not come to us with an
offer that satisfies not only what we
owed right now but what we are going to
be owed and what we are valued going
forward as this contract matures so we
can attract and retain Pilots
to counteract the effects that we have
seen with our Pilots leaving
then I don't know if we're going to be
able to meet these ambitious growth
plans both sides committed to hammering
out a deal we cannot risk the long-term
future of the company to avoid a
short-term one-off cost of a strike and
and therefore we have to find the
resolution that makes sense for both
parties the longer this drags on the
greater the costs we're looking at north
of 10 million dollars a day that WestJet
and Onyx are going to be on the hook for
as the strike drags on Rival carriers
adding flights ready to capture market
share during this turbulent time and
gaviola Global News Toronto
in Alberta nearly 100 fires are burning
now many of them out of control and
smoke is blanketing much of the province
there is some good news for some of the
people who were forced to flee their
homes nitu garcha got a rare close-up
look at progress in one of the hardest
hit communities Nita what did you
discover
Donna there is some excitement here in
the town of Valley View tonight as some
of the nearly 2 000 residents were being
allowed back home have made it home
before part of the highway to town
closed late this afternoon fire
officials say a barrier has been
established in some of the most
vulnerable areas but not far from here
the threat looms for other communities
including Sturgeon Lake Cree Nation
where we went inside the fire zone and
got an inside look at the firefight
turning off Range Road 230 here to head
westbound the home of more than 1500
people from Sturgeon Lake Cree Nation
Northwest of Edmonton looks dramatically
different from when a wildfire forced
them out two weeks ago there was a
residential structure here on the
property that was taken out by the fire
this RCMP escorted tour gives us a
glimpse of the destruction
as well as the fire fight from the
ground and the air there's 36 homes that
were initially lost and then another two
yesterday so let the fire still actively
going in our community so it's going to
be a massive undertaking Chief Sheldon
Sunshine fled to Grand Prairie an
evacuation Center here has registered
hundreds I have never seen anything like
this in my life like much of Alberta
Grand Prairie is blanketed in smoke your
lungs are very precious so you want to
protect them it burns your eyes it's
been like this for days maybe even a
week now it's crazy the county has been
surrounded by evacuation orders and out
of control wildfires and while some
people who were ordered to leave have
been allowed back home there are still
concerns Grand Prairie itself a
community of more than 60 thousand
people could be forced out as well it's
going to be traumatic for some
individuals who haven't seen because
after the fire goes through the
landscape is going to be different than
what it was pre-fire as of right now
there's there's no threat to Grand
Prairie so but it's I think it's a
message for everybody across Northern
Alberta right now just to ensure that
you are prepared to go in in the event
that you have to for Fox Creek there is
growing threat officials say the
Wildfire has moved closer to the
community from all directions Wednesday
afternoon our global news crews were
told to leave as flames were coming
towards the town
and drivers looking for fuel were
quickly helped by RCMP before being
warned a highway closure could be
imminent
back in Sturgeon Lake Cree Nation the
chief says with the Wildfire still so
active they're taking it day by day
while Valley View residents are being
allowed back home Sturgeon Lake Cree
Nation and Fox Creek are about two weeks
into their evacuations which still have
no end in sight Donna all right need
through Garcia in Valley View Alberta
thanks
an election campaign is in full swing in
Alberta the polls suggest the NDP and
the United conservative party are in a
virtual tie so there's lots of
anticipation about the televised debate
tonight and this morning Alberta's
ethics commissioner released a report
that found Danielle Smith in her
capacity as Premier violated the
conflict of interest act Heather urich's
West is with me from Calgary Heather
this will surely come up in the debate
tonight what did the ethics commissioner
find exactly
yeah Donna this is related to the
illegal blockade at the couth border
crossing in early 2022 and allegations
that Danielle Smith tried to interfere
in the justice system by having charges
against those involved in the blockade
withdrawn they also they came from a CBC
report that alleged someone from Smith's
office sent emails to the crown
prosecutor's office Smith's own
admission that she had spoken with her
justice Minister about it and an
11-minute taped phone call Smith had
with archer pawlowski a man that has
since been found guilty of inciting
protesters to commit Mischief now after
investigating these allegations the
commissioner found that there was an
improper attempt to influence the
independence of the legal system well
she found no evidence of Smith's office
sending emails those conversations with
Justice Minister Tyler Chandra were
problematic speaking to an attorney
general about a specific ongoing
criminal case in the way that Premier
Smith did is not acceptable the
commissioner wrote in the whole scheme
of things it is a threat to democracy
now Heather I know these things are hard
to ascertain but do observers think this
could influence how some people vote
yeah we know that Daniel Smith and
Rachel notley continue to be neck and
neck and of course tonight the two
leaders face off in a highly anticipated
debate now political analyst Jason
Ribeiro believes this report has ramped
up the stakes for both sides tonight
if this ends up dominating some of the
focus and ends up underlining that
notion of trust as we know albertans are
really thought thinking about who to
trust in this election especially those
swing voters who could stay home this is
going to be something that they then
need to look at
it is important to note also that the
ethics commissioner is not recommending
any sanctions against Smith and is
asking the province to consider adopting
legislation that would prevent these
kinds of reports from being released
during election campaigns as the timing
of this release could potentially hold a
lot of sway Donna all right Heather
York's West in Calgary tonight thanks
there's a big Municipal change coming to
Ontario the provincial government has
table legislation to dissolve the peel
region which includes two of the fastest
growing municipalities in Canada if
passed the split we'll make Mississauga
Brampton and Caledon independent cities
by 2025. it is complex shared services
like policing affordable housing and
water treatment will have to be divided
up a transition board will work to
ensure that's fair and balanced and
explore new property tax Arrangements
it's unclear what will happen to the
Region's 5 000 full-time employees the
Ontario government says the goal is to
reduce red tape and improve efficiency
prime minister Justin Trudeau is in
Hiroshima Japan ahead of the G7 Summit
which starts tomorrow that city was
decimated by an American atomic bomb in
1945 and Japan intends to amplify the
message that nuclear weapons have no
place in Modern Warfare Mackenzie gray
is traveling with the Prime Minister and
is in Japan tonight
Donna the Prime Minister and other world
leaders have arrived in Japan for the G7
but as a countries who aren't here that
will dominate the conversation we stand
up for the shared values including
supporting the brave people Ukraine as
they defend their Sovereign territory
expect to hear the president's refrain
repeated by all G7 members
as the war in Ukraine will be the top
issue but there isn't expected to be any
new sanctions against Moscow instead the
leaders will work to shore up existing
actions that would be a very timely
message for the G7 to convey the setting
for the summit chosen to underscore
concerns over the war half a million
people lived in Hiroshima Hiroshima was
leveled in 1945 when the U.S dropped the
first atomic bomb on the city killing
seventy thousand people instantly
it's the hometown of the Japanese prime
minister who's hoping to use the memory
of the bombing to push the other leaders
on nuclear disarmament more than 77
years we have the history in fridge no
nuclear weapons were used we need to
respect that which that is never again
but Vladimir Putin's also been clear
that Russia could use tactical nuclear
weapons in Ukraine and Japan's neighbors
are also increasing their stockpiles
North Korea is developing and
strengthening its nuclear Arsenal China
is building up its strategic new Square
forces very quickly how China
strategically targets other countries
economies is the other major issue all
G7 members oppose beijing's frequently
used tactic of slapping punitive trade
measures on countries when they have a
disagreement but find a consensus around
the table on how to counter it could be
a challenge with countries like France
saying they don't want the summit to be
viewed as anti-china we
won't China become responsible
International
responsible member of the International
Community the prime minister is expected
to have a number of one-on-one meetings
with world leaders while in Japan
including with U.S President Joe Biden
Donna all right Mackenzie gray and
Hiroshima Japan thanks
guys
before he got to Japan prime minister
Trudeau made a special trip to the
Canadian Korean War Memorial in South
Korea it honors the 26 000 Canadians who
served in the Korean War and it sits at
the site of the battle of Cape young
where Canadian troops held the line in a
fierce battle halting in advance by
Chinese and North Korean forces ten
Canadians were killed 23 wounded and
Trudeau opened a new hiking trail called
the peace Trail which spans the area of
that strategic battle it's been 70 years
since the Korean war ended more than 500
Canadians died in the conflict
the federal government is planning to
join a class-action lawsuit in British
Columbia accusing a company of
recklessly marketing opioids if
certified the office of the mental
health and addictions Minister says it
will take part in legal action against
McKinsey and Company the office says it
wants all governments to recover health
care costs from any companies that acted
inappropriately in marketing and
distributing opioids that includes
McKinsey which helped Market Oxycontin
the lawsuit is expected to be certified
in 2024.
Italy's deadly disaster coming up a
terrible toll from catastrophic flooding
foreign
[Music]
bodies have been found in Northern Italy
where six months worth of rain has
fallen in a day and a half the flooding
is catastrophic more than 20 Rivers have
burst their Banks and there have been
almost 300 landslides 13 people have
been killed the body of one woman Swept
Away by floodwaters was found 20
kilometers from her home thousands have
had to flee people say the water Rose so
fast they had minutes to get out of
their homes
one of the world's oldest surviving
biblical manuscripts has sold at auction
for 38 million dollars U.S the Codex
Sassoon leather-bound and hand written
on parchment is believed to be 1100
years old it contains a nearly complete
Hebrew Bible it was bought on behalf of
the American friends of Anu Museum of
the Jewish people in Tel Aviv Israel and
it will become part of the Museum's core
collection
still ahead how human Smugglers are
getting migrants across the St Lawrence
River
foreign
migrants crossing the Canada U.S border
often turn to human Smugglers to help
they pay for what can be a treacherous
Journey there's been an influx of people
crossing the turbulent St Lawrence River
in a region that spans Ontario Quebec
and the U.S border Jeff Semple went
there and spoke with a woman who's been
convicted of human trafficking to find
out why she did it and how lucrative it
can be
where the Saint Lawrence River flows
from Ontario into Quebec human Smugglers
are plying their trade you're organizing
them to be safely brought somewhere
we're protecting this young mother's
identity She was recently convicted of
smuggling migrants across the Canada U.S
border and these people are more than
willing and they beg They begged you
know like please please help me she's
from Aqua Sesame Mohawk nation and now
lives in neighboring Cornwall the small
city is wedged between Ontario Quebec
Mohawk territory and New York State the
cluster of border crossings islands and
jurisdictions make it an ideal Target
for Smugglers
in our vehicle away from prying eyes she
outlines how the industry operates
there's people in Montreal okay right
and that would be an agency she says
these agencies in Montreal Ottawa and
Toronto are typically paid around twenty
thousand dollars per person to arrange
passage across the border you have these
big agencies and then you're the little
guy she would receive around six
thousand dollars to hire a team with a
boat and Driver she says most of the
migrants in Canada were from Eastern
Europe or southeast Asia desperate to
connect with family or a job in the U.S
and she too was desperate we're not all
bad people you're trying to make a
living you need to do what you have to
do it's either you watch your kids
starve and you lose them or you figure
out a way to help them she says the
migrant safety was her top priority but
the same can't be said for everyone this
has fast become one of the most popular
routes for migrants trying to cross the
border illegally between Canada and the
United States it's only about a
15-minute boat ride to get across to the
other side but the Waters of the St
Lawrence can at times be treacherous and
even deadly
in late March two migrant families from
India and Romania drowned after their
boat capsized trying to cross into the
U.S the Roma family lived in Canada for
five years but were ordered deported the
youngest victims just one and two years
old
police are now hunting for the boat's
owner a local suspected of smuggling
unfortunately it it gives a black eye to
all Mohawk people of our Posse this
Mohawk historian grew up on these Waters
he says the boat capsized where two
rivers the Saint Regis and St Lawrence
converge and It's Tricky out there and
if a wind comes about then that could
easily upset a small watercraft despite
the danger the number of illegal
Crossings here has climbed significantly
this year possibly due in part to the
recent closing of nearby wroxim road but
it's a jurisdictional nightmare this
Aqua Sesame journalist's office
straddles the Border but that would be
considered the U.S you take a few steps
and you're considered to be in Canada
noting just how difficult The Crossing
is to police immigration is such a big
problem everywhere and we're such a
small community trying to deal with it
she and others here believe the Mohawk
Nation should have greater resources and
authority to patrol these waterways to
stem the tide of migrants making a
dangerous Trek Jeff Semple Global News
aguasasny
police procession next the funeral for
the latest Canadian police officer
killed in the line of duty
family friends and colleagues of another
police officer killed in the line of
duty paid their respects today Ontario
Provincial Police Sergeant Eric Mueller
was shot and killed last week while
responding to a call as Mike drolet
explains his death is the latest
incident putting the spotlight on the
increasingly dangerous role of being a
police officer
to miss little Nixon Tyler a boy with
dreams of following in the family
tradition of policing it's still too
young to fully understand the
seriousness of this occasion definitely
emotional
want to be here Nixon and his mother
watched as 9 000 officers marched in
honor of Sergeant Eric Mueller who died
a week ago responding to an early
morning report of gunshots in a
community just east of Ottawa two other
officers were wounded in what police say
was an ambush a 39-year-old man was
arrested and charged with first degree
murder and two counts of attempted
murder we need to ask ourselves
if our police officers the very ones we
rely upon for our Safety and Security
are not safe
than who is Mueller is the ninth police
officer in Canada to be killed in the
line of duty since September which
represents a sharp increase from the
historical average of 2.7 per year
criminologists point to bail reform
issues and a mental health crisis as
reasons for why it's not a statistical
blip suggesting this could be the most
dangerous time ever to be a police
officer that's the fact that they're
occurring uh almost in succession and
and many of them are acts of violence
that you don't traditionally see in in
Canada these are not uh you know
shootouts or or an officer being
surprised by somebody with a knife these
are in in many cases intentional
ambushes
um that again historically I think
people would equate with with U.S style
violence Eric was everything to our
family Mueller a 21-year veteran was
remembered as a prankster with a big
heart who leaves behind a wife two
infant children and a legion of friends
struggling to come to terms with such a
Monumental law loss everyone that met
Eric grew to love him
and I will miss you my friend
but I will see you again someday
microlight Global News Toronto
and that is global national for this
Thursday I'm Donna Friesen tonight's
your Canada is this beautiful nighttime
shot of downtown Montreal we'd love to
see your Canada please email it to
viewers at globalnational.com and thanks
for watching our Nasser will be at the
anchor desk tomorrow and I'll see you
Saturday for the new reality bye-bye
[Music]
thank you